this German company has been crafting
nutcrackers since 1928 they make them
out of linden wood because it's
lightweight and easy to carve to make
the nutcracker torsos workers cut a long
piece of octagonal-shaped linden into
torso sized chunks a conveyor feeds the
pieces into a multi station lathe the
first station rounds out the Octagon
then forms the basic torso shape the
second station finalizes the shape the
next four station sand the wood so that
the wood stain they'll apply later on
will penetrate evenly next the torsos go
into a vertical router three at a time
it cuts a notch in each torso for the
lever that opens and closes the
nutcrackers mouth next the torso goes to
a drilling machine the machine
simultaneously drills all the holes
required to attach the body parts they
stay in each torso a dark color
once the stain dries they spray on two
coats of semi-gloss slacker
meanwhile an automatic lathe shapes the
nutcrackers head workers attach a nose
then cut holes for the eyes they spray
on a touch of red paint to simulate a
sun-kissed nose and rosy cheeks with a
steady hand they paint the whites of the
eyes and the eyebrows once the paint
dries they apply glue to the center of
each eye then attach an iris and pupil
native enamel tin now they align the
head with the torso and screw the parts
together after decorating the coat with
buttons and a buckle they glue a strip
of rabbit fur hair to the head they also
glue on a rabbit fur beard to camouflage
the notch for the lever then they mount
the torso onto the legs which where
painted on boots and stand on a wooden
base then this Nutcracker percussionist
gets his drum along with arms and
drumsticks
they top them off with a hat made of
spray-painted wood most of the
nutcrackers parts join together with
wooden dowels a large dowel running
across the notch and the torso is the
axle on which the leper rotates